yeah outdoors was the place to be this
weekend whether you were watching the
game or you did have the the tv outside
it was gorgeous lots of 70s even 78
degrees
on friday and then low 70s for the
weekend we're going to continue that
trend today and then things are going to
come crashing down tomorrow seeing a few
high clouds around the valley right now
already but we will have a mostly sunny
valentine's day lots of 40s couple of
neighborhoods in the 30s seven hills
red rock and nellis at 39 everybody else
still in the 40s and not too much in the
way of wind we will start to get some
breezes later today and tonight and then
downright windy for tuesday 21 in
caliani freezing in indian springs we've
got 30's in parum this morning a little
chilly long enough cold enough for long
sleeves and sweaters light jackets 46 in
laughlin 42 in boulder city we are still
doing fine as far as the southwest goes
it was 81 in inglewood for the kickoff
yesterday it was so warm as we expected
it would be we do have some rain and
snow moving into the northwest
temperatures though in the 40s right now
but look at those single digits across
the northern plains
there is going to be warmer air that
gets pulled up to the middle of the
country by wednesday as our system in
the west will start making its way
eastward and look at all the cold teens
and 20s in the eastern half of the
country with some snow around the great
lakes moving over to the northeast
these are actually fire weather alerts
for the planes the southern plains and
around the four corners as this low
pressure system drops into the west and
the first thing we're going to notice
are these high clouds the second thing
will be a lot of wind tomorrow so here
come the high clouds for today still
again a lot of sunshine and good warmth
73 for today but all this wind is a
signal that things will change and these
are wind advisories all these areas of
blue tomorrow 7 a.m to 7 p.m for all of
southern nevada
northwest arizona and southeast
california so enjoy your loverly
valentine's day 73 degrees and i know
70s are a little too soon for this time
of year so we'll get back to more normal
60s windy with a slight chance of valley
showers tomorrow and a better chance of
mountain snow very limited on moisture
though so it'll be gone and we'll be
back to sunshine cooler weather hangs
around for a few days and then low 70s
to start presidents day weekend monday
looks cooler again